[Music]
League of Legends fans will remember MSI
2019 for a very long time from liquids
impossible upset over tournament
favorites Invictus gaming 2g to historic
an na vs EU grand final is what most
western fans dream of and liquid and g2s
unexpected climb to the top has a lot of
people saying that the mythical gap the
difference in scale between the west and
Korea may have finally closed but has it
to conquer champion first of all what is
the gap the term started out as a way
for elite fans to describe the
difference between Korea's most dominant
teams and everybody else but after 2018
that saw China dominate the West's
greatest teams the Institute to love the
two biggest Asian regions together the
gap hadn't closed it was just one more
opponent on the other side it was China
and Korea and then everybody else the
past months we haven't seen some very
very big changes in the offseason and
the most important one and definitely
the most shocking one must have been
caps joining g2f perks moving to the
bottling position hello everybody this
is Carlos Osler we have decided to make
an incredibly radical lineup change and
I know not everybody is on board with
this change but we definitely are and
are very confident that this is the
right choice so with this lineup we
intend to accomplish what is a and has
always been a dream of ours in a dream
of mine personally and which is winning
world's coming I mean how can you take
one of the best EU mid laners move him
into the ADC position so you can make
room for the best mid laner in Europe I
think there's a better likelihood the
team crashes and burns and fails than
succeeds can it work yes of course at
the whole point of super teams but I'm
not gonna buy into the hype yet once
they prove to me it'll work then I will
believe that you two can finally be good
on the international scene consistently
but until then it's a super team curse
that I'm more afraid of starting for
loves teams and I thought you two looked
the most interesting they fail assuming
that way that I wanna play they have a
like a very aggressive mindset and I'll
try to go more ham and just like force
mistakes and make your own mistakes but
then also get an advantage and try to
get snowboard
to get the shutdown gold is worth so
much party caps is coming as well oh
right through the wall
sleepy trouble trouble Oh their business
now he dashes fourth quarter belt
uses the ulti instant cleanse from cat
battle star nemesis baiting a man period
as the double dashboard cap says hey
maybe I've had the opportunity here does
get locked up they're gonna kick off for
a little more on the run but no the
perfect
oh geez who will silence anyone but
doubted them and they will fight for the
title okay we double double twitch chat
press f to pay respects because oh geez
funeral is coming up
meanwhile on the other side of the world
Team Liquid made changes to their roster
hi I am Jensen didn't even leave it for
Team Liquid I want to announce that
we're gonna have core jayjay as a
starting member of our league of Legends
team I am here with Korra JJ
congratulations on being arts spring
split 2019 MVPs makes that a very scary
carry friend as impact goes in the wall
comes out in the back carry and deadly
it down team Lizbeth already won the
fight but how much more can they find
contract wants to get us up away the
passive will be wasted here he goes if
the blob let's and only buys a couple of
extra seconds golden Guardians will not
make anything else happen it back they
stick around play too long the lose frog
they're gonna lose everything
and they cannot get out I do not know
why this team hesitated he spots a Katy
with the void seeker is this the play
rocket plane wants to answer back can
looks at Jackson
answer both back by Sven now running
away for v3 on the map smithy is down
Acadian has no smite though they want to
try to finish this but it
like wit when the fights it is just
enormous at this point of the game Nolan
came content tented slovakia's hungry
for his first final the Erickson's gotta
fall to rest his team is gone
liquid tie the record it's three LCS
titles in a row
despite their domestic when it was hard
to expect a lot from Team Liquid going
into MSI they looked like a powerful
team packed with talent on paper they
weren't a names best shot and
international success but any fans have
been disappointed too many times
I'm she left she lying to all these
super minions and misfits are going to
do it they get a Russian XSP the Wolves
rookies these up side with the Nexus
open these Mets pit push themself I run
right into the quarterfinals and there
it is
an EU bead na of the day not just what's
the GSMA evade them in the first game
this time who revenge it's there for all
of Europe it seems and going into MSI it
was clear that the meta favored fast
aggressive teams who played around
strong solo laners seems like Invictus
gaming the defending world champions and
SKT the returning Korean Cannes Team
Liquid might have looked good on paper
but a lot of na fans were still thinking
about just how big the gap seemed the
thing that I G does really well is they
correctly assess like early game win
conditions of their composition and
enemy composition like way better than
anyone else right so they would come in
and it would be like okay they're the
ones who can see that that Hitler will
become like the dictator at the very
very beginning and they kill them as a
baby that's how good they are at
shutting down enemy team strategies I
just don't think that anyone's gonna be
able to get ahead far enough over SKT to
stop them from being as a team of five
players just better in a five-on-five
situation for Team Liquid the group
stage went somewhat as expected they
swept Fung who buffalo split with g2 and
flash wolves and didn't take a game off
of IG or SKT still it was double lifts
first time out of groups at an
international event
I mean feels amazing I don't know I
don't know what to say like everyone
everything that I did and everyone that
I interacted with my whole career like
all the things that happened it led to
this so I'm just feel really grateful I
feel really really happy but also really
peaceful but Invictus gaming or through
the group stage in fact they had the
best record in MSI history going nine
and one with only a single lost SKT they
looked like exactly what the world is
afraid of IG one world and didn't make
any changes to their roster simply put
they looked unstoppable
if IG tries to continue the fight they
are gonna be four versus five but the
show
the tribe meanwhile on Kennon does have
teleporting they're using the robot
right into the Baron was spotted now
first it is in the ward inside the
payment teepee use they're gonna burn
this one down but they will be at our
game just barely in time is it turns
gonna get in to raise the perfectness
gaming it here comes the teamfight
slicing over the top that one kill
already traded back though the Akali
jumps in for a kill the projectile of
already out of a triple
he's slaughtering Platteville's he bites
the Quadra
not since bangkok titans got crushed
four years ago Invictus gaming smash the
world record they smash as Katie and I
gr 4 so when they pick Team Liquid for
their semi-final opponent it seemed like
a foregone conclusion I definitely I
think feel like Team Liquid could be
more competitive in this series and some
of the voices I've heard around but I
think Invictus gaming are the huge
overwhelming favorites I have them down
as 3/1
we've already seen IG in group stages
and regular seasons be a little bit more
loose and then in playoffs really
turning on that's happening today
IG will 3-0 team liquids I got a mini
game for you to yell fnatic had the
fastest world championship against IG
just lasts longer than fnatic 10 you're
looking at 89 minutes I think it's gonna
be at 300 but just try to hold on but
things didn't work out the way everyone
expected seemed liquid without their big
engaged mechanisms gonna have a very
difficult time to video
let's double kill over the impact
politics nifty will - IG now in full
retreat the shot
rookie in the shining and Fridays I'm
this could be big for the shop Brittany
that's a trouble get himself away just
barely nice kick from negative core
James in trouble
Jackie strikes dance above Jackie balls
and this game is just a blood but are
you doing where are you IG teleport
themselves right on top of Team Liquid
only to counter-attack instantly
from here taken down one more text
here's the deal
for the last remaining member Invictus
gaming team liquid finds they're still
looking to maybe find this fight xfinity
is gonna be put to sleep
damn liquid will do it Peters East
island vacation
liquids win against IG was probably the
most significant victory in the history
of an a-league legends and it was one of
the biggest upsets the game has ever
seen now let's talk about G chips the
things understand about this roster is
that they weren't just a dominant
domestic team they conquered Europe by
being one of the most creative to use in
the world they flex picks and used
unorthodox strategies they even played
funnel in the final despite rice
attempts to pass a strat out of the game
here's the thing they can play whatever
the [ __ ] they weren't it's unbelievable
so and then you have a really creative
coaching stuff that also allows them
with their madness they pick heroes
because they like the skin not because
it makes sense in their setup it doesn't
make any sense and an MSI they only got
more creative this is a squad that will
go for aggressive plays that will make
moves that other teams are like adds a
60-40 maybe we shouldn't do that g2 says
60/40 that's ten more in our favor that
we need it's like what spawn was talking
about in game number one of our cast
it's this idea of the creativity that
they don't play Shantanu League of
Legends that they will change up the
temple became the course of the game and
they will force you to play reactive
they will force you to play on their
child's g-tube lead a high-risk
high-reward style and MSI sometimes that
was enough to beat SKT other times it
meant dropping games to fong foo so
heading into the semi finals against SKT
geez you were confident but analysts had
no idea what to predict I think like the
sentiment is is that there's more
questions than there are answers coming
into this best box I agree with
everything that is al rides and shocks
are talking about but you know the after
yesterday the 2o victory that g2 had
over SKT feels like it means nothing now
yeah without a doubt I think a lot a lot
is up in the air given the victory for
TL / IG and kind of that ramp up for SKT
near the end
the dazzle will not find the target g2r
solo ANCA study very very careful that
one defensing his chances already get
one that's a second kill the g-tube the
tangos it's buy some time and look at it
he's going to the right the tiger is
down take it out by cap but at what cost
yet comes played the dragon strike his
balls barbecued the picks up a kill did
now Tate he's running on two folks he's
got double buffs available look at the
power cores from first he's in so much
trouble
it is still e taken down by Teddy a
little bit of exchange yeah capsules or
to use the perfect execution it goes all
the way back in with the flip five point
strike picks up the kill - mata now
younger-looking understand this that's a
double kill for taxi crashes over the
wall never here comes card charges into
him for devastating effect maker is not
done he's got himself a mega doesn't
matter
Katie are running for their lives
captures trying to find the kill that
matches the troublemakers alone but the
more you got one at Samantha where is
Timmy follow his aged people that's the
law he's dead yeah goes into the pit g2
eSports have been gifted and donated a
parent from SKT
the parent the cat beat damn champions
can fool gods can bleed where were you
when the West brews up to conquer
champions g2 eSports eliminates SK
Telecom North America faced Europe at
the other side
it was a finals that no one could have
predicted na versus EU league's oldest
and most amiable rivalry one that has
not mattered on this scale since season
two
a Western team was guaranteed to lift
the trophy we saw the show talking about
this uni rivalry that it's existed since
before season one to me the most
exciting thing about this chapter of it
is it's no longer you and na fighting
over table scraps they are now fighting
to be the best in the world but in the
end that tournament that moment belong
to g2 once again and they look for these
kills a big charter knocking on the back
line it's already one kill make it a
second as these team living members that
are falling fast and furious g2 esports
in commanding fashion will take Game one
attempt for impact they find a slow they
find almost those tiny ankles gonna
bring the stop punch this community
fight and may God be still
slicing up teamliquid and suddenly it's
one person's the world and he cannot
stop it G to look at a sub 30-minute win
and there is single game away from your
first ever FSI trophy
we're playing [ __ ] goods yeah feel
like every Lane is not lose about and
airing a booth matchups at home I don't
want to be that guy right put your Hawk
game away from winning in the side seats
you unwilling to be stopped the tourists
still in their eyes for this flight ng
to back
from children before this might be lace
inside of the face inside of 18 minutes
and g2 ripped through the hearts of Team
Liquid a North American path as they
secure themselves in the top on the
world this is what peak League of
Legends looks like and it comes from
Europe a world record g2 eSports 3
wonder that it would be the fastest
international boeuf I've ever played and
he was right
but while the finals were a
disappointment for na both Western teams
got to go home with their heads held
high at Worlds 2018 the West proved they
could go toe-to-toe with the best and
some analysts dared to dream it's
exciting and it's hopeful I think I'll
be crushing if Korea just bounced back
and they started destroying everybody
again but it is great to see that after
a couple years of development and growth
that these other regions that have been
playing second fiddle to lck can finally
compete now he's a consistency before
I'm truly gonna buy into this hype frame
that this parity and that gap is closed
but an msi the west proved they could
win I mean we had we've had our two best
international results ever now back to
back that is extremely promising I think
that is so exciting you know as far as a
time to be an na fan and you know and I
look back to to fnatic you know making
finals last year world and they got
blasted right and caps is now here
winning in an international title and
showing people is achievable it's not
just that you know it in though if
you're Western team if you're from you
or na you are only playing for scrap so
you can actually be the best team in the
world and I think you know g2 has shown
that and that's so exciting now has the
gap really closed well that kind of
depends on how you define the gap Korea
and China still have an incredible depth
of talent that the West just doesn't so
if you pit the fifth-place teams in each
region against each other it probably
wouldn't be close and that means Eastern
teams will still get better practice in
their home regions come world North
American and European hopefuls will
still have a hell of a mountain to climb
but this is a huge change in a
conversation Western teams will always
have to work extremely hard to beat
their Eastern rivals after all we're
talking about the very best teams in the
world but when it comes to each region's
best the days of China and Korea being
utterly unbeatable are over when world
2019 kicks off every major region should
believe that they can win
because they can and a few love League
of Legends
there's nothing more exciting than that
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]